millions of kenyans are about to vote
for their next president here are some
key facts on the election and why it
matters
kenya's capital is plastered with
posters and placards as every single
position of political power in the
country is up for grabs and of course
the key battle is for the presidency
there are two men currently in the
league william ruto current deputy
president and self-proclaimed hustler is
up against former prime minister ryla
odinga who's running for his fifth time
just over 22 million kenyans have
registered to vote in this election and
around 40 of them are under the age of
35 with such a large young population
facing high unemployment rates and
rising cost of living this election is
crucial
[Applause]
ryla odinga has come forward as a
paternal figure baba and is offering
around 60 a month for families here as
well as universal healthcare
william ruto has gone a different route
engaging with young people as the
champion of hustlers and promising them
more job opportunities
with food and fuel costs becoming
increasingly unaffordable it's no
surprise the economy is at the heart of
this election
[Music]
it's a close race and one of the main
concerns around this election is the
potential for violence
we met people who've left the capital
until there's a clearer sense of what's
to come
these fears are rooted in past trauma
after the 2007 election at least a
thousand people were killed more than
half a million displaced when the
outcome was contested
since then there's been a real push for
a free and fair democratic process from
people here and despite both candidates
hinting that they may contest the
outcome many are optimistic that this
time will pass peacefully
kenya is the largest economy in east
africa and is often deemed an island of
stability now this label glosses over
the country's complicated history
especially around elections but given
the country's role in peace processes
around the region it's pretty well
deserved the prevailing stereotype
around africans and democracy that
tribal violence often reigns supreme is
one that kenyans have worked hard to
upend and whether or not this election
outcome sparks unrest many have assured
us that it won't be along ethnic lines